oh can you open the door oz and ozer
fetterman in pennsylvania
yeah where we go oh my gosh
is that it grace come here
say hey chris this is where where is it
where where is it come on get down
that's yours
mine was blue can you see me oh get down
here come on i see your bling looks your
face
this is the only chris this is this is
chris poole we got it
all right yeah
this is
all right alex is going to eat it
chris you want to stay in here and watch
it it's gone
i love the symbology of a coffin that's
really sweet okay all right have you
ever seen have you ever seen boondock
saints i mean i've seen symbolism of all
time i had to do the focus wow this is
really taped on here
read the warning i'm going to read it
off no i can't get in here it's oh so
too tight so chris actually had his own
oh
chris is eating he just he just eats
them yeah he just says he like opens him
up puts in the bag no way no he does not
oh my gosh okay look at the literature
oh boy wow
this is not i destroyed i don't like
this symbolism
okay this is where's the chip what this
is
right here with it it's kind of like a
condom it kind of has kind of vibes i
don't know a lot less safe i think he's
stalling no i'm not face the reaper i'm
facing come on this is content i agree i
just want you to do this i'm a pimp on a
blimp and i'm eating this for you dan
crenshaw i know you didn't like me so
this will hopefully the chat room is
going crazy
i'm not even watching the show
i'm not even watching the chat
i have a little water but this is for uh
many little more i just want to say this
is for all the people locked up for
january 6. you guys i'm doing this for
you guys i'm i'm pouring one out for my
homies and um to my favorite big booty
latina i eat this chip for you
alexandria ocasio-cortez or as i call
you my sweet angel
oh my gosh he did it he's gonna die it's
funny because like i'm watching this and
he's just eating a chip and i'm like i
don't know
is it is it good it's hot
it's hot it's pretty hot it's pretty hot
so far we have pretty hot crunchy lip
smacking i love it really painful yeah
no it's not it's just a kind of like a
glassy feeling like classy like a light
bulb
wait wait wait wait wait wait the
challenge is that you're not supposed to
drink any water for like an hour or
something what why not
look at it there's way
there's there's ratings
if you can last one minute
yeah
read the thing it says on it it's like
bring some milk chris if you're
listening
no i have the hiccups all of a sudden oh
my wow it's hot alex is gonna die oh and
luke was right you're going to feel it
twice
wow
alex is dead
screw the challenge take some water
milk christmas if you're listening
hey look look it says if you can last
five minutes you're powerless 10 minutes
is powerful 30 minutes of supercharged
if you last one hour you're invincible
did you drink water already not yet
you got it you got to go on you got to
someone said he can't drink anything he
can't drink anything it's it's they're
supposed to for one hour for one hour
all right to get to be invincible
alex gonna do some jumping jacks put
that energy to good use i'm about to
puke nope
are you really gonna puke right there
is it is it that bad
this is hot
i mean bro if you want to drink the
water i'm not going to stop you i think
i have some raw cosmic milk downstairs
yeah we have those coffees that's pets
milk it's not for human consumption it's
getting hotter it's getting hotter
that's great
eat your eat your questions
or drinking anything oh my god
yeah so it's if you make it five minutes
you like you lose i guess alex you got
this it's hot though
i feel all right you hang there grunting
and i'll read more super chats
it feels like the devil's urinating in
my mouth
all right all right jeremy hernan wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
jeremy hernan says started late because
bjj class goes to 9pm but i haven't had
this much fun since labonte and jones
were on the show yeah we had we we we
were gonna have we had alex jones and i
was like phil we need someone who can
like help us keep alex jones you know
contained and he was like yeah yeah no i
could do it i got it and then and then
when alex jones started saying stuff
phil just looks at him goes yeah
i was like what are you doing no
you like you he set me up
how are you doing i'm not doing well at
all crying so i burned so bad
did it taste did it taste good kinda i
mean the flavor profile wasn't that bad
you're crying
don't die oh it hurts casualty if i die
maybe i'll go out of my pain a little
bit you couldn't hurt you can uh it's
been how long has been three minutes oh
it's been like three four i think four
if you go ten minutes you're powerful
all right so i'll tell you powerful
that's right
i'm one of the most powerful men ever i
told aoc she has a big booty that means
all the power that i need i'm just gonna
have it three super chat i gotta read
more man
all right don't die dick and balls says
great name yeah i enlisted in the us
army in 2005 it paid e1 privates 1200 a
month how sad american treats at so
america treated soldiers and vets just
get some food stamps bro quit
complaining man campbell harris go get
some food snacks come back from the dad
to
tell you to get food stamps
are you
i think that's a well doesn't say you
can't do that actually okay yeah the
rules that you couldn't eat or drink
tongue
a little bit of graphene i already have
i already took the vaccine so it's okay
yeah alex is a good one eric miller says
a black mermaid falls in love with a
rich white man in exchange for her right
to be a human she has to sacrifice her
voice if she wants to speak again she
has to seduce him to kiss her sounds
like a disney movie um here we go
all right we'll grab some more super
chats here corn pop he says welcome back
luke
well there you go thanks for having me
it's good to be back i'm having a lot of
fun here it's awesome
[Laughter]
i'm contacting my lawyer i signed a
whatever i don't expect this to be
you know
protect you from indemnity
and the members only said i wouldn't
want to be anywhere else in the world
but here right now
i'm very happy
all right let's say uh
daim kang says facebook is issuing
warnings on people's accounts for
sharing freedom tune's newest jordan
peterson video wow saying it violated
their community guidelines regarding
hate speech shout out to our favorite
big booty man alex
yeah i have myocarditis now
it was worth it though
uh freedom tunes put out a couple of
really funny ones they put out uh if
jordan peterson really was an incel and
it's really funny it's him when he i
don't want to give away the jokes it's
just really funny and then he did fixing
leftist memes again we got a shout out
because they were like that one they
were like homophobe sheamus did an
episode with tim case like did an
episode i was co-hosted that show for
seven months
oh my mouth my mouth is like it's like
numb i don't even i know it feels like
i've used
the hundred behind
you're gonna barf it kind of feels like
trash can't see it right now
to your right bro alex alex
alex is dead did he just take a dump no
i'm just trying to just the the pain
no my brain is now numb you seem like
you're actually getting better no it
feels good honestly the pain i like it i
have a bdsm fetish so i need this this
is why i like kamilahara so much because
she punishes me so bad it feels good
all right alex all right oh wait wait
here's a good one julie girl 1313 says
just saw a katie hobbs commercial
bashing carrie lake on your show we made
it
we're gonna carry lake we're big fans
and uh
katie hobbs using our show in a
commercial wow okay you know thanks for
your money
well they didn't pay us they just used
it
it's funny when people are like can use
a clip from your show and i'm like in
what context and they're like we're
commenting on it for a news video and
i'm like are you joking that's legal
it's fair use you're gonna ask me
people take my videos all the time and
just you know whatever well but have you
guys seen the internet drama between who
are these podcasts and centering john i
know that's kind of niche but no
basically he he's like trying to fake
sue them because they use his content
for commentary but as long as it's
transformed you know transformational
you can do that so for the people
playing at home if you watch somebody
you can react to it that's why reaction
content is so big i can't barely speak
so my mouth it feels like it's really
spit are you giving up you're gonna
drink no how many minutes are i'm never
giving up i'm never quitting hey dad
cringy sorry none of you guys
you can until you
it says you can't eat or drink for an
hour to be invincible
okay well i never said that
you know i did say that i haven't you
know you're two minutes away from being
able to drink and being powerful okay
just two more minutes okay i feel like i
just had an abortion in my mouth so as
you're allowed to say that on youtube no
i'm pro-abortion so you're allowed to
say that
yeah
i think that's illegal i think yeah all
right let's see
uh where are we at
waffle sensei says you have to engage
with them no matter how culty they are
it's not about changing the cultist
minds it's about allowing normal people
to see what a conversation looks like
between a knowledgeable person and a
cultist
we have milk
oh my gosh how much time wait wait wait
don't drink it just wait
where did that milk come from i don't
know probably my personal stash luke's
personal stash well we know a baby
formula there's a baby formula shortly
one more one more minute just to be sure
because i think stuff right there i
think it's one more minute
that's some non-statist milk i'll just
tell you this much nancy pelosi's breast
milk is what this
is five hundred dollars
i got a visual i got a video
why
why did you make me have a visual right
now now that's healthy what are you
talking about she's solving the formula
crisis herself thank you how are you
doing alex i'm not doing well i mean i'm
just all right you're good
all right that's it ten minutes you're
powerful don't throw up
wait you don't just drink it you gotta
like swish it around a little bit
because what happens is the oils
the oils get all over and the milk and
the fat and the calcium it helps it is
helping yeah it is immediately helping
yeah but you gotta like swish it around
man i'm a pimp on a blimp you gave me
the pocky uh chip challenge and i grind
and shine because there's no amount of
food if this is an unlimited shrimp
buffet i could do it if it was an
unlimited anything buffet if you put
food in front of me i am like a dog and
you know why it's because when my
parents got divorced him they actually
fought for custody of our family dog
more than me so i was technically raised
by he would go with me on the weekends
wherever i went so i was with my german
shepherd primo more than my parents so
that's why i'm an animal oh wait
i made a mistake
it's only been nine minutes
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you